you know it's kind of funny because i
was looking at his timeline and he's um
he
his first marriage if i'm not mistaken
if it was his first marriage was during
a time when amber heard wasn't even born
like there's about a 23-year age gap
between the two of them if i understood
that correctly but she's quite a bit
younger she actually
she actually looked like quite the
number when she was younger i've not
seen her before in films if i'm honest
like
it's
you know watching the trial her face
seems recognizable but when you see the
younger photographs of her um i can see
how she caught some eyes but i don't
recall her in any films johnny depp on
the other hand you know his name i mean
you've seen him in a bunch of big
uh productions and i'm sure he's got
quite the uh do you know what he's worth
that i don't know like someone stole
millions of dollars from him uh he
wasn't paying attention to it like a lot
of very wealthy
uh people in the entertainment business
and sports uh
superstars they get ripped off a lot uh
and they put the wrong people in charge
of their finances they're not paying
attention
with drug and alcohol problems so
i don't know what he's worth now but
according to
a google result as a four days ago it's
estimated 150 million
uh and he's named one of the highest
paid actors in recent years salary his
average salary seemed to be about 20
million a year according to this
yeah i heard the number 22 and a half
million for the pirates films that's
what he was getting pirates of the
caribbean which he lost by the way as a
result of herds allegations didn't he
right it sounds based on the testimony
so far that disney doesn't want to
rehire him right and uh
his testimony was the feelings mutual
which is sad you know he built his
franchise and i'm sure he got a piece of
the merchandise if he was smart about it
and everything else so you know right
now he's not getting any offers as far
as the testimony uh is telling us and
that's sad what else is he going to do
yeah well
deal with the trial right now apparently
um
all right so
let's walk through the first point over
here
okay uh the key takeaways from this
trial at least uh initially
if there's one thing i want anybody
watching this to think about it's that
this could happen to anyone maybe with
not with all the zeros behind their name
okay and with all the money but there's
tons of amber herds walking around out
there hundreds of thousands and the
reason why this case is so important and
i think it's important to watch or know
about is because it's being televised
right so if you came to work with me
today you wouldn't be able to see a case
where there's this type of woman who
took advantage of a guy who may not be
as successful as depp but since my case
wasn't televised you wouldn't know about
it here they're hope they're opening the
doors to the world and everyone's
fascinated i want you to remember this
that this could happen to you if you're
not careful if you don't vet carefully
or you marry the wrong person
you may not pay a million dollars a
month for 14 months but
you could be paying a lot of what you
own or what you've worked for and we
want you to try to avoid that so on a on
a percentage basis i'm just curious so
on a percentage basis
during the time that you've practiced
law
how often do you see like this level of
crazy pop up
uh often often i want to just share a
quick anecdote with you uh it's not
unusual for me to run into opposing
counsel who i'm really facing off
against but there's a lot of mutual
respect and i've had cases where
opposing counsel both men and women
uh will just
come up to me with their palms
outstretched towards the sky and say
he married her
he married her all right
we're not killing each other there's
mutual respect we know
the ability of the other one
but it's just that's all i have to say
he married her so i want to pass that
along something guys might not
ordinarily say don't be that guy who
married her without carefully vetting
because so it happens often
you can't imagine especially over the
last couple years with the delays in uh
court with covid covert you know kind of
shut down a lot of the family courts or
slowed them down until they moved to
zoom hearings so
i've had cases where
we i might represent guy who gives a
great off you know
great offer right off the bat and she
just holds out for more she wants her
day in court
uh it winds through the courts and
16 months later she ends up getting less
than what was offered originally you
can't force somebody to settle if
they're hell-bent on burning in the
earth so you want to be careful about
that but to answer your question
directly fairly often fairly often
all right um yeah let's hop into these
points over here because i mean we're
looking at what's essentially an apex
predator narcissistic hysteronic
borderline violent
um
yeah i'll let you take it from there
because i mean you've got some good
points here on this road matt all right
so uh she if you watch the trial or you
watch some of the clips from the trial
depp had a target on his back and he had
one itis right so
she was going to find a way to marry him
he asked her for a prenup uh
according to some of the uh
things i've read and a post-nup and she
got violent on them and she just really
uh spun out of control that's a huge red
flag so
he's already rich he's already famous
he's a handsome guy but he's very
vulnerable why because she doesn't have
clear boundaries and she was able to
just
run away with what she wanted to do
um he had drug and alcohol problems that
were well documented and when you lose
touch with reality that's bad you know
if you don't if you're not careful you
could end up doing things that are
against your better judgment and when
you're persuaded by
beauty
it's not a good recipe it's going to end
up in a disaster so
it was what i would call the perfect
storm for her she had the guy who could
really help her in her career
he's loaded he's a multi-millionaire had
an island or maybe still even does have
one
multiple penthouses in the same building
from all accounts he was very generous
too he let her friends move into the
penthouses or
it's just insane how generous he was but
she really took advantage of him it
seems like
uh some of the testimony that's come out
so far in the trial indicates
all of this was pre-planned uh you know
she recorded them and made herself a
victim and here he is now under a ton of
stress his career is in shambles
and it could have all been avoided if he
just took some precautions and maybe
listened to those close to him and
didn't marry her
once you marry somebody
uh you're bound to them under the law
she knew it
he
i think the his uh the mother of his
children he wasn't married to so
you would think
wow you know he knows marriage isn't
necessary to have a family life if
that's what he wanted
but
he fell off the tracks and
he's been married a few times before if
i'm not mistaken uh
depp and makeup artist lori ann allison
were married from 83 to 85. he dated uh
jennifer gray
uh went on a rider
he tattooed her name on his body by the
way i'm sure he had that covered up
since
um vanessa parodies uh lily rose melody
that's a daughter um
yeah but i mean he like he knew of her
for a good i mean 2014 was when they got
engaged for a good five years before
they walk down the aisle i mean that
that should have been enough time for
him to figure out what she was made of
yeah but
even if
five years if he was with i don't think
he was with herd for five years but no
but he knew of her since 2009 but they
were started dating in 2012 from what i
got from the timeline so i mean he dated
her for at least three years yeah and uh
he had he was blue pildy he wanted a
marrier he wanted to
make her his wife now the tattoo that he
had uh
it said winona
for life and he had it shortened to wino
for life
so
come on you know
that's not a good decision to start
tattooing people's name on your body but
look he can do whatever he wants he's
very successful guy
my heart goes out to him
at some level you know
because he is just agonizing sitting in
that courtroom and
uh
i i found his testimony credible from
what i saw i really did
um he's
he's an actor do you think there was any
acting in that you know just trying to
be the devil's advocate both of them are
yeah her her testimony so far without a
doubt was scripted uh acting a lot of
from her
crying but no tears and
you know i just really felt that his was
more heartfelt and more honest so i
can't wait uh when the trial resumes
she'll be on cross-examination
and uh his lawyers will really be able
to dig in to what she said
to try to expose her for what she really
is so it'll be interesting the sad part
is it's costing millions of dollars in
legal fees and it could have all really
been avoided if he just didn't marry her
he could still have been good to her but
once you bring her in under that state
law umbrella of marriage
uh she felt entitled as if she could
just abuse him and it seems like that's
what she did they never had any kids
together no they never had any kids
together she did uh she'd ended up
having a a kid in 2020 apparently
through a surrogate
yeah so she's a mother of a young child
uh
you know i don't know
if if you have to go through any sort of
psychological testing for that but
no
yeah
with enough money i guess you can have a
source i've said this before dumb people
and crazy people are out breeding smart
people right now without a doubt without
a doubt you know they don't think things
through
so
we'll go back to depp again you know his
mindset is i'm
wealthy i get whatever i want i get
great drugs and alcohol
uh
you know what's the worst that could
happen some guys thrive on chaos it's
the violence that i have a real problem
with where she's hitting them and um
that should never be tolerated nobody
should be able to hit another person
like that it's just
so abusive
yeah and she actually has has a history
of
violence and there was a dv uh domestic
violence charge against her with that
woman that she was dating and up until
2009.
they dropped it afterwards but there was
you know the uh the call made and the
charge filed hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you